no
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en las 24 este es
un magacín informativo 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre liliana
valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad una
empresa de tecnología en nigeria
desarrolló un dispositivo enfriador que
permitiría transportar vacunas a
temperatura ideal al igual que sangre
para transfusiones u otros insumos
médicos el invento sería especial
utilidad en el marco de las campañas de
inoculación contra el cob y del 19 las
patas de sierra leona en áfrica
occidental esconden paisajes
paradisíacos que antes eran frecuentados
por celebridades europeas sin embargo la
guerra civil española imagen del país y
ahora los hoteleros trabajan para
recuperar el sector
y este 21 de mayo se conmemoran los 170
años de la abolición legal de la
esclavización en colombia que tuvo lugar
el 21 de mayo de 1851 autoridades
nacionales trabajar en una agenda
destinada a aumentar la visibilidad de
esta comunidad y sus aportes a la
construcción de la nación
iniciamos entonces con la información in
africa siete días y empezamos con temas
de tecnología porque la empresa
nigeriana desarrolló un enfriador
electrónico que mantiene la sangre o las
vacunas a la temperatura adecuada según
las necesidades de cada territorio el
dispositivo podría representar una
solución para la distribución de vacunas
contra el cubit 19 en zonas rurales del
continente africano
este motociclista viene a buscar
muestras de sangre a una clínica en el
suroeste de nigeria la clínica carece de
equipos y las muestras deben ser
transportadas a un laboratorio
especializado solíamos pedirle a los
pacientes que fueran al laboratorio pero
con este servicio es mucho más fácil el
llevar las muestras al laboratorio
este enfriador es especial fue diseñado
por una empresa y nigeriana de
tecnología puede acceder a wifi y la
temperatura se puede regular los
clientes tienen la posibilidad de
rastrear sus productos a través de una
aplicación móvil
el desafío era mantener bolsas de hielo
para transportar vacunas o muestras al
centro de la ciudad
en wet snap pero con este dispositivo
que funciona con baterías solar no se
necesita infraestructura y funciona bien
las baterías solares pueden durar hasta
24 horas el gobierno decidió emplear a
esta empresa para que lo ayude a
transportar productos que deben
mantenerse a bajas temperaturas
nigeria acaba de ordenar una cámara
frigorífica especial para guardar las
vacunas que se utilizarán para luchar
contra el coronavirus
vamos ahora a la reserva natural de capi
y en el sur de kenia donde a los
camellos se les están realizando pruebas
de pcr con el objetivo de detectar el
virus del mersey el colon a virus del
síndrome respiratorio de oriente medio
es un primo del coi 19 peligroso también
para los humanos veamos el informe
en esta reserva de kenia científicos
están rastreando el mercè una especie de
coronavirus diferente al cob y 19 pero
también peligroso para los humanos
estos camellos están siendo sometidos a
una prueba de pcr el objetivo prevenir
una próxima pandemia commonwealth vamos
muchachos lento tranquilos la mayor
parte del tiempo antes de empezar a
tomar muestras en el camello el
acercamiento es lo más importante se
cree que fue durante el contacto cercano
con camellos que el vídeo se habría
transmitido a los humanos los pastores
de camellos suelen estar obligados a
trabajar en grupos de tres para
controlar a los mamíferos durante la
prueba
para un análisis de sangre se supone que
es rápido y se puede hacer un clic para
que no sienta dolor lo que se hace es
una prueba en el morro del camello hay
que pulsar profundo y si es muy
desagradable igual que para un ser
humano
el virus del mre se apareció en 2012
desencadenando una epidemia
principalmente en arabia saudita donde
habría dejado cientos de víctimas en un
estudio de 2014 realizado por este
laboratorio de nairobi sólo el 5%
humanos evaluados tenían anticuerpos
efectivos contra el coronavirus merco
hay un interés renovado en todo lo
relacionado con los virus todo lo
relacionado con las enfermedades que se
transmiten de los animales a los humanos
debido al cob y 19 porque entendemos que
es fundamental seguir intentando
entender la biología de este tipo de
patógenos y a menudo es difícil hacerlo
debido a problemas de financiación y así
esté renovado interés global nos ha
ayudado a permitirnos hacer este trabajo
tan importante en 2020 el grupo de
expertos en biodiversidad de la onu
advirtió que las pandemias serían más
frecuentes en el futuro debido a los
contactos cada vez más regulares entre
animales salvajes ganados y seres
humanos debido a la destrucción del
medio ambiente
y cambiamos de información porque a
sudáfrica es uno de los países africanos
donde se permite el porte y consumo de
cannabis pero no su venta ni
comercialización sin embargo la
legislación más avanzada sobre el tema
se encuentra en lesotho el pequeño reino
ya empezó a exportar la hierba hacia
europa los detalles con nuestro
corresponsal salem fayad
en sudáfrica y el uso personal de la
marihuana es legal desde septiembre de
2018 acá en el país se pueden tener
hasta 600 gramos de marihuana por
persona y hasta un límite de 1.2
kilogramos por hogar el número ilimitado
de semillas también es posible y también
es legal el regalar o donar semillas o
hasta 100 gramos de marihuana a amigos o
conocidos pero no es legal de ninguna
manera que haya una transacción
monetaria es decir está ilegalizada la
venta del producto aquí en el sur de
áfrica también es muy interesante el
caso de lesotho es un país que ha tenido
unas regulaciones muy abiertas con
respecto al uso del cannabis desde 2008
se ha convertido en el primer país
africano que tiene una autorización para
exportar a países de la unión europea el
ingrediente activo de la marihuana para
fines medicinales pasamos a temas de
turismo porque las playas de sierra
leona alguna vez fueron uno de los
destinos favoritos de viajeros europeos
sin embargo la guerra civil empañó la
imagen del país y este renglón de la
economía prácticamente desapareció ahora
hoteleros intentan reactivar el sector y
llamar la atención del mundo sobre este
paraíso escondido
sierra leona un pequeño paraíso olvidado
con su arena blanca y sus aguas
cristalinas el país bordea una de las
costas más bellas de áfrica occidental
sin embargo en los últimos 30 años el
turismo aquí ha sido casi inexistente
las pocas personas que han hecho el
viaje están encantadas y sorprendidos
por la gran belleza de las playas no se
pueden ver muchas playas como esta en el
mundo
hemos viajado mucho y nos gusta mucho
estar aquí rabo tengo no tengo y río de
la sierra la hora no aparece en los
folletos turísticos desde 1991
el año en que todo cambio cuando el país
se sumió en una guerra civil
a los 11 años de conflicto devastaron la
mayor parte de las infraestructuras de
sierra leona
solo quedan algunos lugares turísticos
de antes de la guerra
como estas ruinas ahora ocultas tras la
vegetación
aquí hubo un hotel donde yo soy figura
trabajaba como empleado éste era el
restaurante el lugar para dormir el
lugar para vivir esa parte era una
discoteca paradisíaca con un escenario y
música en la noche a finales de la
década de 1980 sierra leona era un punto
de interés turístico cerca de 100.000
visitantes franceses adinerados venían
cada año disfrutar de sus paisajes de
ensueño pero desde entonces el país ha
luchado por recrear una imagen de
belleza y tranquilidad aunque algunos
todavía tienen fe en el potencial del
país como el director de este hotel que
ha invertido recientemente 19 millones
de euros en nuevas instalaciones el
objetivo cuando se construyó este hotel
era atraer a personas de otros países de
áfrica occidental y de europa
enero y febrero fueron buenos pensamos
que íbamos a hacer pero
desafortunadamente llegó el cob y en
realidad se han reconstruido pocos
hoteles lo que deja los turistas con
pocas opciones y con estancias caras
pero mientras sierra leona continúa su
ardua
hacia la recuperación concentra sus
esfuerzos en atraer de nuevo turistas
europeos para que visitan sus playas
algún día
pasamos a temas de la diáspora porque
este 21 de mayo se conmemoran los 170
años de la abolición de la esclavitud en
colombia que tuvo lugar en 1851 es el
tercer país de américa con mayor
porcentaje de población afro después de
eeuu y brasil
por eso la efeméride tomar relevancia
como una oportunidad para reivindicar la
herencia africana en colombia por el
tema hablamos con el director de
poblaciones del ministerio de cultura de
ese país luiz adriano que nos habló
sobre la importancia de esta comunidad
el año 2021 es el año de la libertad en
colombia en conmemoración a los 170 años
de evolución de la esclavización un año
que nos va a permitir justamente generar
espacios de reflexión presentar los
aportes protagónico otras comidas negras
afrocolombianas raizales y palenqueras
la construcción de nación es un año
donde nos permitirá reconocer que la
diversidad en colombia nuestra gran
riqueza y los pueblos negros son los
mayores aportantes de esta diversidad
son sus manifestaciones culturales sus
tradiciones y sus lenguas propia las que
han hecho posible que este país
reconozca en el tránsito de los
territorios de la sre territorio de
reconocer la esencia de un país desde
las propias diversidades el pueblo negro
en colombia en este año realmente podrá
tener la oportunidad de cerrar brechas
de erradicar estereotipos pero sobre
todo de permitir reconocer en este país
en la diversidad
gran riqueza y justamente para
conmemorar los 170 años de la abolición
de la esclavitud el ministerio de
cultura de colombia ha programado
numerosas actividades en asocio con
organizaciones sociales y colectivos
culturales y severiano también nos
amplio sobre este tema
bueno realmente es muy importante muy
importante adelantar una formación como
ésta porque permite visibilizar el
aporte de las poblaciones negras
afrocolombianas raizales y palenqueras
que para colombia son las poblaciones de
la afrodescendencia en la construcción
de nación los pueblos negros en colombia
los pueblos afrodescendiente han sido
protagónicos en la construcción de
nación pero sistemáticamente durante la
historia durante 170 nación
invisibilizados
y esa invisibilización se ha reflejado
además de sus indicadores actuales
todavía muy distantes o unos indicadores
que permitan una buenas condiciones de
vida lo que buscamos con esta
conmemoración es no solamente poner en
la agenda pública la discusión acerca
del aporte a las comunidades negras no
solamente visibilizar lo sino generar
estrategias medidas y distintas acciones
que ayuden al cierre de brechas sociales
de la población afrodescendiente en
colombia pero también en la erradicación
de estereotipos
y permitir que las historias las gestas
las luchas de nuestros pueblos negros de
nuestros pueblos afrodescendientes sean
puestos en valor sean reconocidos y
hagan parte integral de la nueva
historia que colombia debe narrar hacia
adelante
y finalizamos con música justamente
desde colombia y una canción dedicada a
los casi 12 millones de afro colombianos
que viven actualmente en ese país según
cifras de organizaciones sociales se
trata de la canción titulada somos los
prietos del grupo chocquibtown en
colaboración con el rapero alexis plate
juntos le cantan el orgullo de ser
afrodescendientes colombianos y a los
importantes aportes de esta comunidad a
la construcción de ese país suramericano
así finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días pero ustedes pueden continuar
con más en nuestra página web las 24
punto com para ampliar la información de
américa latina y el mundo quédense con
más de esa programación somos france24
en el flow que lo que prevalece si
quiero captar mi sueño a ser real no se
rinde el que nació donde por todo hay
que luchar mi estilo es diferente al del
montón que suene la marimba mientras
bailamos
el negro y eso ya se comprobó pero todo
lo negro no es malo como dice la
televisión
y yo
yo yo yo yo sólo los vientos afro de
colombia que representamos donde quieras
te lo digo